ولكن هذا الصباح يوم RMC شابة
مسلمة محجبة كانت والدتها
أول ضحية للشاحنة على
منتزه des anglais في نيس هو
اليوم محجبة تدعي نفسها
مسلمة وتقول إنني لا أرى حتى
كيف نسأل عنا
تميز عن أولئك الذين ليس لديهم ما يفعلونه
معنا
ماتت والدته الحبيبة تحت عجلات
صوفا بولين من ماهلر هذا التونسي
أولا بيننا منذ أن تحدثت
هجمات لطيفة عام 2016 الرعب
من هجمات كل هؤلاء القتلى من الجميع
هؤلاء الجرحى جيدون نتحدث عنه أقل
أطفاله ذبحوا أطفاله
الجرحى من قبل هؤلاء الناس الذين ينهون بهم
حياة الكراسي المتحركة أ
الرعب أنت تتفق معي
المصطلح الثاني مثل أ ب في كل مكان
يتفق العالم التونسي على أنه كان
رصدت بالفعل من قبل الشرطة
كان قد حكم عليهم بالفعل أنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك
ليس عالقًا ، لم يكن عالقًا ولكنهم
لقد حُكم عليّ بالفعل إذا فعلت ذلك
لو كان رئيسا لكان قد طُرد
مثل كل الأجانب المحكوم عليهم
العدالة حتى لا يكون هناك هو
لم يكن هناك بحلول الشهر الثالث على الرغم من ذلك
تريد من الجيد جدًا أن تقول ذلك
لا علاقة له بالإسلام إلا هذا
تونسي مثل كل الآخرين يقتل هناك
اسمه الذي يقول لبوذا وعظيم
الذي سأقتلك يقول - هو كذلك
كبير لذا سأقتلك لا يقول
الله عظيم فقتلك
أن يقولها المسلمون لبعضهم البعض ويقولون لي
لكني لا أتعرف عليه
أفهم ومن الواضح أن هناك
المسلمون المسالمون لحسن الحظ لكن
المشكلة هي الإسلام أقول لهم
خلال الحملة فمن الضروري ذلك
المسلمون يبتعدون عن أنفسهم
مع نص قرآني
لأن النص القرآني pons the
حرب مع اليهود و
كل المسيحيين في حبس
المرأة تدفع إلى الله القمع
المثليون جنسيا الشرسة كل هذا
الطبقة السياسية الدعوة الإسلامية لا
إنه الإسلام و طارق أو بوند يقول ذلك
نفسه لذا فإن المشكلة برمتها وهذا
وهو عيب يجب أن نجعلها تنفجر
يجب طرده غير مملح
عليك جهد يجب أن نبذلها
جماعيا هذا هو أننا
لديك لاستعادة قواعد
المحاكاة ويجب أن يقول المسلمون
هنا نريد أن نكون فرنسيين
نحن نعتبر أن إسلامنا ليس كذلك
أن الروحانية هي ممارسة
دينية لكنها ليست
القانون المدني قانون العقوبات أمة أو حتى
حضارة وهذا ليس ما
يمر اليوم في كثير
الأحياء اليوم لدينا
أسلمة الأحياء
كل شيء